juste une part dans gpa mais que quand
comment est-ce que du coup vous nous
imaginez
est-ce que vous que vous comment vous y
menacer physiquement enfin comment vous
m'imaginez moi physiquement
alors moi je vais vous répondre très
troublant non
moi je pense pas comme ça ah oui je
pense pas à l' enveloppe je pense à la
lettre ah ouais je pense pas
l'enveloppent c'est beau jeu sadran sauf
pour les créatures féminines je pense
alors à ras bord non sérieusement je
pense pas l'enveloppent je pense par
contre dans les vois je vous réponds
vous venez de parler l'a pas longtemps
ça c'est matthieu delormeau
ouais mais tu sais le l'animateur est
bien connu il avait reconnu oui le noir
mais c'est de me choper noir aux hommes
mais je pense à vous quand vous étiez
petit garçon oui alors vous n'avez pas
parlé assez longtemps pour je voudrais
malaisie ben non non mais si mal mais ça
va mais bah ça me touche beaucoup ce que
vous dites mais voilà je me dis toujours
quand vous écoutez une voie qu'est ce
que vous vous dites sur la personne et
ce grand petit blond gros méchant et
regarde mais je sais pas qu'est-ce que
non je vois jouer je vois jouer avec
avec certains jouets vous aviez quand
j'étais je vais faire voyant dans la
voyais en envoyant ce qu'est ce que vous
voulez dire sur mathieu parce que c'est
assez intéressant moi je trouve ça de
savoir oui c'est touchant
mais on sait pas parler assez pour que
j'entends bien sa voix mais je veux dire
je vois ça je vois quand il était petit
j'ai en fait quelqu'un de 2 et solitaire
mais quand même qui aviez envie de
communiquer ce n'était pas toujours
évident mais je devrais pas dire ça
comme ça où vous pouvez savoir si la
personne en face de vous je parle pas
que de moi mais c'est quelqu'un de
sincère qui est le méchant dont il faut
se méfier
quelqu'un qui joue un rôle qui est
lui-même quand il vous parle justement
non non je non jeu
j'aime bien voir où et dans les voix des
gens mais mais mais souvent je dis pas
ce que je vois pas ce que ça aurait
serré mais dans cette couveuse où
j'étais c'était la folie parce que il y
avait des infirmières qui passaient et
qui croyait pas beaucoup en mes chances
de survie alors moi je devais en plus me
calmer et puis il croit vraiment en fait
ce que j'ai découvert c'est que j'ai
fait confiance à la vie est elle la vie
elle m'a fait confiance dans le sang ce
média temps accroche toi d'avoir ça va
bien se passer finalement et qu'est ce
que je regrette pas je veux dire ici
avec avait tué natacha le cirill tout le
monde à mr sim public
[Applaudissements]